let's get to hatred mail today is a
hatred mail day here's a reminder about
what hatred mail is it's like taking an
apple pie filling it with pages from the
Old Testament topping it with hollow
points and serving it with a side of
homophobia Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom allright
this hatred mail is going to bring up an
issue that is a common issue on this
program let me say that let's dig into
it anyone with a brain can figure out
that massive immigration from third
world countries as the end of America
that's the master plan and David Pakman
half Jew is all for this it's the white
race and their culture that's at stake
here I am Muslim of Middle Eastern
descent and the war is on the whites
white genocide research and it all makes
sense
end of Western civilization and
demographics equals the new world order
be proud of your heritage and race
defend your people and culture by every
means possible scumbags like David
Pakman are all for the destruction of
Western civilization there's so many
contradictions here because sometimes I
get critiqued and I I receive
anti-semitic critiques based on the fact
that Jews are just white people right
Jews are part of the group of white
people and then sometimes I'm the the
the recipient of anti-semitic insults
and critiques because Jews are not white
people and in this case as a Jew that it
says half Jew but I can I can attest I'm
full Jew as a Jew I want the destruction
of white people which presumably I am
NOT white I can't figure out the
anti-semites need to get together and
figure out are we going to slam Jews for
just being another group of white people
or are we going to slam Jews for not
being white people I don't understand it
yeah they definitely can't make up their
mind I think that just any way that they
can insult you will probably be
not for them and I think also the the
other contradiction here Pat is wait a
second as the Western Jew I want the
destruction of Western civilization mean
I was born in Argentina and moved to the
United States
I'm Western why would I why would a
westerner want the destruction of
Western civilization
nothing about this makes any sense and
this guy says it he's Middle Eastern a
Middle Eastern descent yet they don't
robably alarcón or not but yet it it not
only would be anti-semitic or racist but
it's also just not logically consistent
yet if I had to bet I would say that's a
lie we get a lot of what what's called
identity flagging where someone will
write it and they say hey I'm part of
this group that is not the usual group
that would say this but the war is on
whites and half Jews are destroying
their bubble but I wouldn't be shocked
that that's just a lie yeah I wouldn't
be shocked either and I think they're
just trying to kind of promote that
self-hating uh self-hatred is a big
thing yeah no doubt about that remember
you can turn hatred mail into something
positive
by using coupon code Patriot 40 when
you'd sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership I got an
email this morning actually from someone
saying David I would really like to be a
david pakman show member but it's a
little expensive and I said hey coupon
code patriot 40 that will give you a 40%
discount and you can keep that discount
for life and they signed up within five
minutes so I call it a win Warby Parker
is offering a free five day home Tryon
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trialed
dot-com slash TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I liked the most and then Warby Parker
put my
prescription lenses in there for me a
lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like $300 for prescription
glasses high which is just insane Warby
Parker glasses start at $95 that's what
mine cost and for every pair of glasses
sold Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker dot-com slash TDP s it costs
nothing